trás
eu me apaixonei por uma garota que
morava no interior de são paulo
como trabalhava no rio
a gente precisava pegar um vôo que
custava em média 600 reais para se ver
apesar desse volta quase sempre vazio
o preço dele nunca baixava então é com o
tempo a conta começou a ficar cara
as viagens tiveram que diminuir o namoro
acabou eu me senti mais ou menos como
esse cara aí abandonado em meio a um
monte de assentos fazer-me cobrassem
tipo os 400 reais valor que eu achava
justo por aquela passagem
provavelmente eu teria viajado mais mais
assentos teriam sido ocupados e
conseqüentemente eles também faturaram
mais só que isso não aconteceu
não aconteceu porque essas empresas
utilizam modelos econômicos feitos há
mais de 50 anos feitos no mundo que não
existe mais que foi reconstruído depois
desse trauma
eu fui tentar entender melhor por que
isso acontece
com certeza não foi por ganância daquela
companhia
os caras estavam tão cegos olhando os
modelos do passado que já faliram e
também ouvir isso acontecer em diversos
outros lugares do mundo em maior ou
menor grau pessoas querendo viajar
empresas tentando proteger preço e mesmo
assim os aviões continuam voando com o
espaço vazio
apesar de eles tentarem fazer de tudo
para vender esses assentos
através de promoções passagem de última
hora e por aí vai
todas estas são soluções
do mundo que não existe mais esse mundo
começou a mudar quando esse cara da capa
da time criou o primeiro browser que
popularizou a internet
o netscape eu tive a sorte de nascer na
geração que viu isso acontecer eu fazia
sistemas para rodar no brasil é dele
depois disso eu tive mais sorte ainda
porque eu decidi fazer alguma coisa
diferente da área de tecnologia e fui
aprender sobre economia comportamental
foi aí que eu percebia que as variáveis
mais importantes de qualquer sistema são
as pessoas e apesar de adorar as
máquinas elas são só o reflexo de nós
mesmos
elas são o acúmulo do nosso conhecimento
que agora carregamos no bolso
não falamos mais sobre mera tecnologia
falamos agora sobre inteligência
artificial um robô uma máquina capaz de
raciocinar como nós seres humanos e
falamos sério não é ficção científica é
ciência ciência da computação se
entrelaçando com a neurociência para
poder replicar o cérebro humano não uma
máquina
olha que loucura mas como isso é
possível como uma máquina pode
desenvolver o raciocínio humano da mesma
forma que nós fizemos ao longo da nossa
evolução para sobreviver
nós tivemos que tivemos que aprender a
construir nosso próprio aprendizado
ou seja nós tivemos que aprender a
aprender essa lição que passam de
geração para geração
agora estamos passando para as máquinas
e chamando isso de machine lane
essa é a principal técnica por trás da
inteligência artificial
o algoritmo mach lane
estão sendo usados para resolver
diversos problemas da sociedade
principalmente na área de economia onde
está aquele problema que eu escrevi no
início as máquinas têm condições de
tomar decisões mais racionais que nós
justamente porque não têm os nossos
vinhos biológicos
o cara que mais estudou os impactos
desse viés da economia
o ganhador do prêmio nobel daniel cama
vocês vão encontrar diversos ted talks
falando sobre ele e sobre as suas
teorias de economia comportamental mas
hoje vai ser a primeira vez que vamos
falar isso à luz do pacto machiline cama
disse que nós não conseguimos tomar
decisões racionais porque o nosso
cérebro não tenha capacidade de enxergar
todas as variáveis de um problema ao
mesmo tempo a explicar isso
ele dividiu fez uma analogia de vídeo no
cérebro em dois sistemas distintos um
rápido ou devagar um sistema rápido as
funções que seriam executadas nele são
as funções de sobrevivência por exemplo
poderia tomar água
já o sistema 2 devagar
ele seria responsável por executar as
funções que podem esperar um pouco como
as nossas decisões de viagem por exemplo
nós agimos nacionalmente quando tentamos
utilizar o sistema rápido pra executar
funções que deveriam ser do sistema
devagar mas nós não fazemos isso
conscientemente
fazemos isso porque o nosso cérebro foi
desenhada assim
não existe espaço energia para executar
todas as funções ao mesmo tempo cada uma
também mostrou que nós é que esses temas
eles interagem e se transforma o tempo
todo através do aprendizado eu vou beber
água está chegando aqui ó
vai ficar muito melhor garante obrigado
agora sim
e é exatamente isso que acontece com uma
sirene através de uma rede neural
artificial os sistemas bom interagido se
transformando e aprendendo a fazer
escolhas melhores
a grande diferença do aprendizado humano
para o aprendizado de máquina é que as
máquinas não têm as nossas limitações
biológicas e por isso não existe sistema
devagar todo o sistema é muito rápido
pra ficar claro como machine lane muda a
lógica do jogo econômico
imagine o seguinte toda vez que a gente
vai comprar um produto ou serviço
a empresa que vende aquilo faz uma
análise de oferta e demanda antes de
definir o preço que a gente vai ter que
pagar essa análise de duas únicas
variáveis funciona perfeitamente
num mundo perfeito que a gente sabe que
não existe no mundo real as pessoas
estão fazendo escolhas baseadas em
diversas outras variáveis
comportamentais como o canal mostrou mas
somente agora com as máquinas
nós temos condições de fazer essa
análise com eficiência em tempo real
então se nós fossemos fazer rodar um
algoritmo the machine lane para tentar
definir o preço mais adequado para cada
situação
seria algo mais ou menos assim com os
milhões de variáveis e correlações para
todos os lados para navegar por esse
modelo
todos nós aqui teríamos que está usando
um óculos de realidade virtual
mas eu acho que nessa imagem já dá pra
ficar claro por que temos que delegará
certas decisões pelas máquinas
qual de nós seres humanos seria capaz de
fazer esse trabalho
eu acho que só numa galeria de arte na
verdade
bom depois daquele episódio do amor e do
avião
minha paixão então passou a ser mostrado
como a economia comportamental ea
inteligência artificial podem juntas
ampliar nossa visão sobre economia e
essa é uma ideia mais simples do que
parece
basta olhar para a realidade das pessoas
enxergar além dos modelos econômicos com
a ajuda das máquinas
vocês devem saber tão bem quanto eu que
a cada viagem que fazemos voltamos um
pouco transformados só acontece porque
novos caminhos neurais são descobertos e
todo o nosso padrão de escolhas muda
foi assim que eu decidi largar o emprego
estável viajei o mundo inteiro e fui
parar no vale do silício
é lá que estão os programadores de
máquinas
o chamado scouters estão reconstruindo
mundo reúne nessa imagem 3 geração de
coder que vocês conhecem bem mas que
devido ao sucesso deles
às vezes a gente esquece como eles
começaram programando máquinas
ele certamente desenvolveram muito bem a
nossa incrível capacidade de aprender a
aprender mas eu acho que além disso eles
aprenderam acreditar
eles acreditaram que poderiam
reconstruir o mundo
e realmente reconstruíram eu
sinceramente não sei se é preciso ser um
poder nesse mundo novo repleto de
máquinas para ser bem sucedido mas eu
tenho certeza de uma coisa é preciso
aprender acreditar porque acreditar
também um aprendizado
obrigado
[Aplausos]